how's ago and everybody it's Warren and
today we have some huge news about
Captain America the writers for the
Captain America trilogy and Avengers in
game have confirmed a huge Captain
America Theory the confirmation of this
theory solves an issue that some fans
were pretty upset about and what some
would consider a huge plot hole to
Avengers endgame not only that but it
opens up the future of the MCU to an
entirely different Captain America I'll
break it all down in this video but
first if you're new be sure to subscribe
to my channel at the 400,000 subscriber
mark I'll be picking three winners to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection so while many fans
were very excited to see Captain America
go back in time and live his life
married to Peggy Carter some fans
weren't that excited about it in fact
some were pretty mad saying that he
shouldn't have gone back in time to live
his life with Peggy Carter because she
lived a happy life with a husband and
two kids and Captain America stayin back
in time to marry Peggy Carter throws the
whole thing off or does it in a recent
interview with thr Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely the writers for
Avengers in game talked about Captain
America stayin back in time to marry
Peggy Carter and it's also important to
note that not only were they the writers
for Avengers in game and Avengers
infinity war but they were also the
writers for the entire Captain America
trilogy Thor the dark world and they
created agent Carter as well and in a
recent interview when asked about
Captain America erasing Peggy Carter's
husband and two kids Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely actually revealed
that the husband and the two kids
actually did not get erased when Captain
America stayed back in time and this is
because Captain America was actually the
mysterious husband and the two kids were
Steve Rogers kids that's right according
to the writers it was always their
intention that Steve Rogers would go
back in time marry Peggy Carter and have
those two kids and the interview Stephen
McFeely said it was always our intention
that he was the father of those two
children but again there are time travel
loopholes for that so at the end of
Avengers endgame when Captain America
decided to stay back in time and marry
Peggy Carter he didn't actually erase
her old husband and two kids he became
her new husband and had two kids with
her according to the writers this was
always there in
including when they wrote Captain
America the Winter Soldier and
introduced her mysterious husband and
two kids and not only does this twist
solve a big problem but it also
introduces many future possibilities in
the same interview Christopher Markus
went on to say it does introduce the
idea that there are two children who
have somewhat super-soldier DNA so we
now have two kids who potentially have
super-soldier DNA who could potentially
go on to be the next Captain America's a
lot is possible with Marvel introducing
the multiverse into the MCU so this
could be something that they explore
later on down the line and who knows
this could even open it up to see a
return of Steve Rogers in the MCU for a
quick cameo but let me know your
thoughts about Steve Rogers being Peggy
Carter's husband that was mentioned in
Captain America the Winter Soldier and
the father of her two kids this whole
entire time let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and again don't
forget about my giveaway at the 400
thousand subscriber mark I will be
picking three winners and each will
choose one item that they want from the
Marvel Legends series collection to be
eligible for the giveaway you must be
subscribed to my channel again don't
forget to comment with your thoughts if
you liked the video give it a thumbs up
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]